Russia if you're listening I hope you're
able to find the 30,000 emails that are
missing if you look at his wife she was
standing there she had nothing to say
she probably maybe she wasn't allowed to
have anything to say you tell me but
plenty of people have written that
nothing you can do folks although the
Second Amendment people maybe there is
Adam inviting the Russians to hack
Hillary Clinton's emails rowing with the
family of a fallen soldier and inciting
violence against his rival Donald Trump
did not have a good summer pundits say
it could be his undoing but how closely
the people who really matter watching
these moments and do they count
Pennsylvania could be make or break for
Donald Trump if he can build on his base
of white blue collar workers here he
could have a shot of the presidency
Meredith da giuseppe works at Doyle's
town's cafe alessio she says this is all
a show for Trump who doesn't know
anything about foreign policy but she is
going to vote for him there's things
that he does say do come out racist they
do come out to meaning and you don't
want to represent yourself that way
bison tourism racist demeaning no that's
how it comes across I truly don't think
that he is customer and teacher Jennifer
Hackett is similarly forgiving of trumps
weaknesses I can tolerate his talk it
doesn't it would not prevent me from
backing him because I feel like the
alternative is a dismal horror if akmal
try this one for a few doors down local
optician erica shank has a different
view and already she's all election
doubt there's so many commercials this
person did this and said this so don't
do this and it's like okay I've we've
heard it all and I don't know if it
really does anything to change anyone's
mind you may not be old mind yeah
that's Hillary no doubt no doubt did you
ever consider Trump no not for a half a
second what you don't hear much of round
here is outright enthusiasm for either
candidate in past elections residents
say these lawns would have been full of
yard signs proudly demonstrating support
for a chosen candidate but driving
around here you just don't see any
people think that could be down to the
fact that Trump and Clinton are the two
least popular candidates of modern times
people keep calling this a lesser of two
evils election in Doylestown bookstore
people have been showing that in a very
muted and polite fashion we have
customers that might come through and
just slowly turn the covers of the books
around and in protest in protest of of
the candidate and then of course we'll
have to go put them back and any front
covers turning more than others at half
the sage it's a bit equal that's a bit
equal of the shunning of the covers
today is labor day the official end of
summer when the election campaign steps
up a gear the signal from doylestown is
that first impressions and general
perceptions rule for many voters efforts
to change them between now and November
will be in vain Amanda Walker Sky News
Doylestown Pennsylvania